[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات
السعوديه والخليج نبدا بالعناوين
لندن تتواجد بالرد على اعدام طهران
لمواطنها وباريس تحذر من الانتهاكات
الايرانيه ضد الاجانب
رغم اعلان
تحت سيطره قوات بلاده
الداخليه السعوديه تعلن عن ضبط اكثر من
15000 مخالفا لانظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال
اسبوع
في الرابعه ايضا
شكاوى على مواقع التواصل في السعوديه من
ارتفاع اسعار تامين السيارات والتي تجاوزت
المئتين في المئه
اداره الملك عبد العزيز وثق بناء العقير
كاول ميناء بحري سعودي على الخليج العربي
مساء الخير استودعات الخارجيه الفرنسيه
مجددا القائم بالاعمال الايراني احتجاجا
على اعدام علي رضا اكبري وقالت الخارجيه
الفرنسيه في بيان انها ابلغت القائم
بالاعمال الايراني فرنسا باشد العبارات
اعدام اكبري وحضرته من ان انتهاكات ايران
المتكرره للقانون الدولي لا يمكن ان تبقى
من دون رد لا سينما فيما يتعلق بمعامله
الرعايه الاجانب الذين تحتجزهم هذه الدوله
بشكل تعسفي
قبل ذلك استدعت الحكومه البريطانيه القائم
بالاعمال الايرانيه على خلفيه اعدام علي
رضا اكبري واكدت ان هذا العمل لن يمر من
دون رد وعبر رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سوناك عن صدمته تجاه اعدام اكبري وقال في
اول رد او رد فعل له ان تنفيذ حكم الاعدام
كان قاسيا وجبانا ووصفه بالعمل الارهابي
من نظام بربري لا يحترم حقوق الانسان ومن
جهته قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس
كليفرليت ان اعدام علي اكبر يستحق الاذان
الشديده بكل العبارات الممكنه
كما دانت منظمه العفو الدوليه على تويتر
قيام طهران باعدام علي رضا اكبر واصفنا
الاعدام بالهجوم الشنيع الذي تشنه ايران
على الحق في الحياه ودعت المنظمه الحكوميه
البريطانيه الى تحقيق بشكل كامل في
اتهامات بتعرضه للتعذيب
دعوه الى لقاء اخير تلقتها مريم زوجه علي
رضا اكبر من طرف احد المسؤولين الايرانيين
بالحضور لرؤيه زوجها في سجنه بطهران ومع
الدعوه وصل اليقين الى مريم بان زوجها في
طريقه الى الاعدام اكبر اختفى عن الامطار
منذ عام 2019 عاد الى ايران من لندن بدعوه
من امين المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
الايراني
وبحسب عائلتي اكبر فانا رضا خضع عقب وصوله
للتحقيق في مقرات سريه مختلفه تابعه
لوزاره الاستخبارات ليتم الاعلان عن
اعدامه واستمر مرحله داخليه غير مسبوقه
تواجه النظام
بشارعا تشعله الاحتجاجات الشعبيه واقتصاد
يكاد ينهار بالاضافه الى الضغوط الغربيه
اعدام علي رضا اكبر المفاجئ شنقا بعد اربع
سنوات من اعتقاله يحمل بين ط وفقه خبراء
محاولاتها تخويف للمحتاجين واشاره لتصفيات
الداخليه في حرب يقودها المتشددون ورساله
للغرب برفض ضغوته اكبر البريطاني الايراني
مزدوجه الجنسيه كان قد شغل بين عمي
1997 و 2001 منصبه نائب وزير الدفاع
الايراني علي شمساني في حكومه محمد خاتمي
وبعد مغادرته ايران والسفر الى النمسا
واسبانيا ثم استقراره في بريطانيا بدا
نشاطه الاقتصادي هناك لعشر سنوات اثر
اعتقال الاكبر وفي تسجيل صوتيا مسرب نشرته
مواقع اعلاميه اكد انه بريء وان التعذيب
الذي خضع له اجبره على الاعتراف امام
الكاميرا بجرائمه لم يرتكبها فتهمه تجسس
التي دفع اكبر حياته بسببها قال في تسجيله
انها مبنيه على قميص وزجاجه عطر كان
قدمهما هديه لعلي شمخاني متسائلا في تسجيل
عن مصير شمخاني المقبل حنان المصري
العربيه
عروب عبد الحق اهلا بك معنا عروب على نشره
الرابعه اذا الجواز البريطاني لم يحمي
اكبر من عقوبه الاعدام من قبل النظام
الايراني فما ابرز ردود الفعل الداخليه
التي رصدتها حتى الان عروب
مرحبا فاطمه من جديد
امام مقر وزاره الخارجيه وزاره الخارجيه
التي كانت يعني خلال الاسبوع الماضي الى
عدم اعدام علي رضا اكبر لكن ايران يبدو
انها مضت طبعا بعمليه الاعدام هذه التي
اثارت ردود فعل همم من الحكومه البريطانيه
بشكل واسع وكما ذكرت اكبر هو مزدوج
الجنسيه بريطاني ايراني وربما هذا كان
يعني هي نقطه نقطه التي ادت الى همم اثاره
ردود فعل غاضبه همم ممكن وصفحه لعمل
لاعدام لاعدام اكبري همم التركيز الان هو
على كيف ستكون شكل الادانه من قبل الحكومه
البريطانيه هناك دعوات كثيره همم الحكومه
البريطانيه اتخاذ موقف اكثر حزما همم للرد
على الاعدام هذا جاي يمسك كلاب اللي وزير
الخارجيه كما ذكرت او كما ذكر خير يعني هو
همم وصف هذه وصف عمليه الاعدام هذه بانها
بانها عمليه يعني جبانه وانها لن تمر مرور
الكرام وبالتالي نحن ننتظر لنرى كيف ستكون
شكل هذه الادانه هناك كانت كثير دعوات من
بعض النواب ايضا قالوا بان على الحكومه
البريطانيه همم المضيء باتخاذ القرار الذي
كانت يعني كان هناك اتجاه وحديث عنه بانها
ستقوم بوضع الحدث الثوري الايراني على
قائمه الارهاب وهنا كانت ايضا دعوات الى
وجوب يعني همم التضييق على بعض المراكز
التي يعتقد بانها تابعه للنظام الايراني
والحرس الثوري على الايراني هنا في لندن
وبالتالي يعني هناك همم الكثير من
التحركات تجاه او للرد على عمليه الاعدام
هذه هو كما ذكرتي طبعا الجواز البريطاني
لاكبر ربما هو الذي همم يعني اثار هذا همم
نوع من الردود الفعل ولكن ياتي هذا توقيت
هذا الاعدام ياتي تزامنا مع عمليات اعدام
همم تطال الكثير من الايرانيين داخل داخل
ايران بسبب مشاركتهم في المظاهرات التي
رايناها في الشارع الايراني خلال الاشهر
الماضيه طيب عروب قبل ان نختم معك هناك
عاجل يريدنا عن وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
والذي يعلن فرض عقوبات على المدعي العام
الايراني اذن هذا كان خبر عاجل وردنا قبل
قليل العروب وسنبقى مع اكتبها عن اي
مستجدات حول هذا الموضوع شكرا لك من لندن
مراسله العربيه عروب عبد الحق
عادت العلاقات البريطانيه الايرانيه
المتوتره منذ عقود الى دائره الضوء بعد
اعدام سلطات النظام الايراني المواطن
البريطاني الايراني علي رضا اكبر وذلك
بتهمه التجسس
علي رضا اكبر مسمارا اخر في نعش علاقات
متوتره بين بريطانيا وايران توتر لم يكن
وليد اللحظه لكنه بدا منذ خمسنيات القرن
الماضي ولا يزال ففي عام
1953 شاركت بريطانيا الى جانب الولايات
المتحده في الاطاحه بحكومه محمد مصدق
واعاده الشام محمد رضا بهلوي الى الحكم
وفي 1980 اغلقت بريطانيا سفارتها في طيران
اما في
اتهمت بريطانيا ايران بالتواصل مع الجيش
الجمهوري الايرلندي المحظور وفي يونيو
2009 جمدت بريطانيا اصول ايرانيه بموجب
عقوبات الغربيه المفروضه بسبب برنامج
ايران النووي
2011 فرضت بريطانيا عقوبات ماليه ايران
وامرت جميع المؤسسات الماليه البريطانيه
بوقف التعامل مع نظراتها الايرانيه والبنك
المركزي الايراني وفي اكتوبر 2022 فرضت
بريطانيا عقوبات على ثلاث شخصيات عسكريه
ايرانيه وشركه لتصنيع المواد الدفاعيه
لتزويد روسيا بطائرات مسيرات تستخدمها
للضرب اهداف في اوكرانيا وفي يناير
اعدم النظام الايراني المواطن البريطاني
الايراني علي رضا اكبر بتهمه التجسس
قضايا خلافيه وملفات شائكه توتر المتصاعد
على مر العقود لا يهدا تلك هي طبيعه
العلاقه التي تفرق ولا تجمع بين لندن
وتهران عصام عبد السلام العربيه
واسعه النطاق وطويله الامد وان اجراءات
بوتين لاعاده تنظيم الاقتصاد والمجمع
الصناعي او المجمع الصناعي العسكري
للاتحاد الروسي تشهد على تحضير روسيا
للانتقال الى الاحكام العرفيه كما انها
تهدف الى تعزيز القوات المسلحه الروسيه
وتهيئه الظروف لاجراء العمليات التي خططت
لها منذ بدايه الحرب الحاليه
هزت سلسله انفجارات العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف كما تم تفعيل الانذار الجوي اثر ضربات
صاروخيه جديده وقال مسؤول في رئاسه
الاوكرانيه ان الهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه
الجديده استهدفت منشات للبنيه التحتيه
للطاقه فكيف ومحيطها من جهته قال الحاكم
العسكري لمنطقه كييف اليكسي كوليبا ان
روسيا استخدمت صواريخ بالستيه في هجمات
اليوم ومن جهته قال حاكم من كل لايف انه
تم رصد اقلاع 17 قادفا نوويه روسيه من
طراز فيما توقع مسؤولون اوكرانيون ان
روسيا تنفذ موجه ضربات صاروخيه عنيفه
اليوم
مقاطع مصوره اظهرت اثر سقوط صاروخ في بلده
كوبيلي كوبي لايف في محيط العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف وذلك بعد ما شنت روسيا
صباح اليوم غارات جديده على مواقع البنيه
التحتيه فكيف وخاركيز ميكو لايف وزابريجيا
وابهر المقطع والمصور احداث الصاروخ حفره
ضخمه بعمق لا يقل عن عشره امتار وقطر يمتد
لثلاثين مترا
من كييف ينضم الينا حذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك معنا حذيفه على نشره
الرابعه ما الجديد لديك على الميدان حتى
الان
تحياتي فاطمه في الحقيقه قبل حوالي 20
دقيقه فقط انطلقت صافرات الانذار مره اخرى
في العاصمه اكيد وتم اعلان حاله التاهب
الجوي ليس فقط في العاصمه كيف وانما في
معظم الولايات ما عدا تقريبا الولايات
الغربيه هي التي خارج نطاق هذا حاله
الانذار الجوي طب الاعلان عن اطلاق صواريخ
جديده من قبل الاتحاد الروسي قبل حوالي 20
دقيقه تحدث في تاليف رئيس الاداره
العسكريه في موكا لايف عن اطلاق صواريخ
جديده قال قبل قليل ايضا قبل حوالي خمس
دقائق تحدث عن اننا لن ااه يعني نقوم بنشر
المعلومات حتى لا يسعد همم جارنا وهنا
يتحدث طبعا عن الجاره همم روسيا ويبدو انه
هنالك استهداف لمدينه نيكا لايف حتى الان
لم يتم الاعلان عن اي اصابات في العاصمه
كيف جديده اتحدث في همم الغاره الاخيره
همم التي استهدفت خمسه مدن ايضا لم يتم
على الاعلان عن ما هي المدن الخمسه دي
تستهدفوا هذه الصواريخ ننتظر طبعا على
المعلومات بالرغم من اعلان حاله الطوارئ
والاداره الجوي فاطمه يعني سابتعد قليلا
بينما احدثك لتشاهدي معي الصوره هنا في
العاصمه كيف كما تشاهدين حاله الانذار
الجوي وحاله التاهب الجوي وعلى المواطنين
ان يلجؤوا الى الملاجيء ولكن على الرغم من
ذلك المواطنين لا يتعاملون بالجديه
المطلوبه مع هذا الامر همم يعني كما
تشاهدين امامك المحاله التجاريه مفتوحه
الناس تتحرك بشكل طبيعي السيارات بشكل
طبيعي طبعا فتح المحاله التجاريه والسماح
بالبيع والشراء والمراكز التجاريه وتواجد
المواطنين داخلها هذا امر مجرب من قبل
السلطات واذا ما تم طبعا الابلاغ من اي
مواطن او تم ااه يعني اذا سجلت الشرطه هذه
المخالفه فيكون هنالك عواقب كبيره وقيمه
على الشخص صاحب المؤسسه لكن على الرغم من
ذلك كما تشاهدين امامك في الصوره
المواطنين يتعاملون بشكل طبيعي ويتحركون
بشكل طبيعي غير همم
الانذار الجوي حتى الان طبعا كما قلت لك
لم يتم تسجيل اي وصول للصواريخ ال 18 قد
يكون طبعا الدفاع الجوي استطاع ان يسقط
هذه الصواريخ قبل ان تصل الى المدن ننتظر
المعلومات المؤكده حول ذلك اما في
الاستهداف الذي تم صباح اليوم فهذا
الاستهداف فاطمه قال العاصمه كيف كوب من
هي قريه في همم ولايه كيف همم وهذه القريه
الاستهداف الذي اطاله وهو طبعا هو جزء من
صاروخه وشضيه سقطت في هذه القريه تضررت
اسقف المنازل تضررت النوافذ الزجاجيه لم
لم ترسل او تسجل اي حاجه
لاصابات بشريه في هذه القريه كذلك هنا في
العاصمه في الدقيقه وهذه المنطقه تم
استهداف للطاقه وايضا نسب حريق جزئي في
همم هذه المنشاه وتم- الحريق وايضا لم
تسجل اصابات تذكر اعلى من شركه الكهرباء
انها تعاملت مع الوضع وعادت بشكل طبيعي
هذه المحطه الى العمل لكن على الرغم ذلك
شركه الكهرباء اعلى حالات عن همم القطعه
الكهرباء يعني الاضطراري في مدينه اكيد
وكذلك في اوديسا اا بعد اعلان حاله
الانذار الجوي الاخيره وهذا فقط امر
احتياطي حتى اذا ما سجل وصول صاروخ
واستهداف لاحدى المنشات يكون الضرر اقل
طبعا اذا ما نشرب حريق والمولدات تعمل
يختلف من ان يجب حريق المولدات لا تعمل
وتكون الاضرار اقل بكثير ايضا سجل وصول
صديه في احدى الشوارع والتضرر سيارتين
وايضا لم ترصد اي اصابات في هنا في
العاصمه كيف ماذا عن المحاور الاخرى حذيفه
هل من المعلومات الوارده من ربما سوليدار
او اي محور اخر يتم القصف فيها الان
نعم القصفه الكبير في
خط الجبهه كان في افديف قتل ثلاثه اشخاص
واصيب ثلاثه اخرون نتيجه الضربات
الصاروخيه التي نفذت على افديتك طبعا
خارقه ايضا تعرضت للقصف طبعا تم اااا قصف
منشات البنيه التحتيه للطاقه ولكن ايضا لم
تسجل اضافه
وانقطعت الكهرباء عن بعض المناطق في مدينه
خارقه في ايضا في خط القتال الرئيسي همم
هنالك اكثر من 20 بلدها تعرضت الضربات
الصاروخيه همم
الحقيقه بين الجانبين وراء جماعه الصواريخ
ايضا مدينه ايضا احدى القرى المحيطه او
القريبه من المدينه من مدينه صرصور ايضا
تعرضت ايضا كان هنالك تسجيل اصابتين همم
قتل شخصان واصيب ثلاثه اخرون ايضا في هذه
البلده القريبه من مدينه خرسون خطى الجبهه
مستمره القتال الوضع في كوبر في لوغانس
تحديدا كما السرقه داي ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول ان تمنع القوات الروسيه
من تحسين وضعها الاستراتيجي والحصول على
الامدادات وتحقق تقدما في اتجاه كوب اسكت
طبعا هنا الهدف هو السيطره على صفاته وعلى
كوبسكم وبعد ذلك ليستر وسيفر ديناسكو شكرا
لكن كيف حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه على كل
هذه المعلومات
اعلانات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
طورت هجومها على محور دنيتك باتجاه بلده
سول وذلك بعد اتمام السيطره على مدينه
سوليدار المجاوره وقالت الدفاع الروسيه في
تقريرها اليوم مجموعات اقتحام بالتعاون مع
وحدات من القوات المحموله جوا ومدعوما من
طيران الجيش وقوات الصواريخ والمدفعيه
قامت بتطوير عملياتها الهجوميه واشاره
الوزاره الاوكرانيه خسرت اكثر من 70 جنديا
وعددا من الدبابات والمصفحات في هذا
المحور خلال يوم واحد فقط
اكد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك
للرئيس الاوكراني فولدي ميرسي لينسكي خلال
اتصال هاتفيين اكد طموح بلاده في تكثيف
الدعم لاكرانيا عسكريا ودبلوماسيا واكد
تزويكييف بدبابات تشالنجر اثنين بالاضافه
الى انظمه مدفعيه وشدد سوناك على مواصله
العمل مع الشركاء الدوليين لتقديم كافه
انواع الدعم بشكل يسمح لاوكرانيا كسب
الحرب وتامين سلا من دائم
حضرت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جنتيلن
الكونجرس من ان الولايات المتحده سوف تصل
الى سقف الدين القانوني الخميس المقبل
وشدد على ان وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
ستبدا مجموعه من الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
المحدده لمنع الولايات المتحده من التخلف
عن سداد ديونها وتابعه الوزيره الامريكيه
ان الاخفاق في الوفاء بالتزامات الحكومه
سيتسبب في ضرر لا يمكن اصلاحها بالنسبه
للاقتصاد الامريكي وحياه جميع الامريكيين
وكذلك بالنسبه للاستقرار المالي العالمي
رابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها
شكاوى على مواقع التواصل في السعوديه من
ارتفاع اسعار تامين السيارات والتي تجاوزت
المئتين في المئه
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت الداخليه
السعوديه عن ان حملاتها الميدانيه اسفلت
عن ضبط اكثر من 15 الف مخالفه لانظمه
الاقامه والعمل وامن الحدود في مختلف
المناطق خلال اسبوع واوضحت الداخليه
بلغ اكثر من ثمانيه الاف مخالف فيما تجاوز
عدد مخالفي نظامي امن الحدود 4,000 مخالف
وبلغ اجمالي مخالفين نظام العمل
2822 مخالفا مشيره الى ان الحملات اسفرت
عن ترحيل اكثر من احد عشر الف مخالفين من
البلاد
ابدا مستخدموه مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
شكاوى من ارتفاع اسعار تامين السيارات في
السعوديه والتي تجاوزت حسب تجارب مستفيدين
على مواقع التواصل المئتين في المئه
مستخدمو تلك المواقع طلب بتشديد الرقابه
من قبل البنك المركزي والجهات المسؤوله
لضغط عمليه الارتفاع غير المبرر حسب رايهم
هذا وكانت الاداره العامه للمرور قد اعلنت
في وقت سابق عن انخفاض الوفيات في
السعوديه نتيجه الحوادث المروريه من 27
حاله لكل مئه الف نسمه في 2016 الى نحو 13
حاله في 2001 2020
حول ذلك ينضم الينا في الاستديو الخبير في
التامين وليد الحميد اهلا بك استاذ وليد
معانا يعني هذا الرقم اكثر من مئتين في
المئه تم رصده من قبل المستخدمين المواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هل هو رقم ربما فيه بعض
المبالغه ام هو رقم حقيقي
للجميع الاطراف سواء على مستوى المؤمن له
العملاء على مستوى شركات تامين على مستوى
القطاع بشكل كبير اليوم قطاع التامين قطاع
جدا مهم قطاع حيوي ساهم في الناس في
المحلي اليوم نسبه المشاركته حوالي واحد
فاصله
48% وما زالت الطموحات اكبر انه يصل الى
خمسه بالميه حسب البنت ماركه والمعدلات
العالميه اليوم هنتكلم على قطاع السيارات
وتامين السيارات يعني قطاع او مجال من
الناس يعني اليوم انت ما تقدر تجدد
استماره او اي اجراء في المرور لا لازم
يكون عندك تامين فلذلك هو مهم اليوم ويعني
الناس حابه يعني تعرفوا شو اسبابها
الخسائر هذه والسبب ال 200% في مؤشرات
كثيره اليوم نسبه الحوادث هي الهايسه
الاكبر بالنسبه لشركات تامين كل ما زادت
عدد الحوادث في
داخل السعوديه او للسيارات المؤمنه كل ما
زاد سعر التامين همم ما في شك مؤخرا تتحدث
عن انخفاض نسبه الحوادث والوفيات اصلا
اللي من بسبب الحوادث اللي تصير في
السعوديه هو هو طبعا مؤخرا اليوم همم
شركات تامين تعتمد على معينه شخص اكتواري
هو دوره يحسيها الحوادث هذه الخسائر اللي
حصلت او سجلت في شركات التامين ومن خلاله
يبني التسعير المناسب لكل شركه تامين على
حذاء
نقطتك جدا مهمه اليوم في مؤشرات كثيره ما
هي بس فقط حوادث اليوم اسعار قطع الغيار
ارتفعت اليوم الورش او الوكالات زادتها
اليوم في مؤشر جديد يعني في السابق كانت
مثلا تقييم السيارات بعد الحادث او قطع
الغيار يعتمد على ورش او يعتمد على همم
الشيخ المعارض اليوم في جهه اسمها تقدير
هي اللي مسؤول عن تقييم السيارات وهي تعمل
اون لاين ف- همم هذه يمكن باحثه الاسباب
اللي ساهمت او جعلت معايير ثابته بالنسبه
لشركات التامين اول في مجال وحوادث في اخذ
وعطاء اليوم تغيرت المعايير همم التقرير
اللي صادر من الجهه الرسميه يعتبر نهائي
وهذه يمكن اعتقد انه في همم
مؤتمر حيقام في شهر ثلاثه لمراجعه
المطالبات هذه والسبب الزياده
هل جميع المستفيدين من تامين السيارات
متضررين من هذا الارتفاع ان يمس ربما مثل
ما ذكرت اللي عندهم حوادث عاليه اللي
عندهم عدم همم ربما همم استمراريه في همم
التامين وما الى ذلك
جدا مهم اليوم عندنا التامين عده محاور
خلينا ناخذ الجانب الاول اللي يخص المؤمن
النوع او العمل اليوم الامين او انت كمؤمن
لك لازم يصير عندك الوائل كامل انك تستمر
في العمليه التامينيه اليوم انت ما تقدر
تجدد الاستماره الا لازم يكون عندك تامين
المهم معنى ان التامين لمده سنه فقط فلازم
يكون عندك الواعي ان كنت تجدد سنه وراء
سنه عشان تقدر تحصل على خصم الولاء اللي
يوصل المرات الى 50%
يعني لما يصير لك حادث لازم تعرف انه اذا
الخطا مش عليك انك يعني ما تقول والله
بسبب هذا شخص والله متضرر لا باحاول
اساعده لا في السجل تامين مهم لازم تحافظ
عليه وهذا يتم مراجعه وكل سنه من قبل
شركات التامين ومن خلاله يتم تسعير السعر
التامين فلذلك انت دورك شخص مؤمن منه انك
تحافظ على السجل التامين هذا ما يكون الا
في الحالات قدر الله صار حادث شركه
تاميرها توقف معك وتحميك من اي تضررات او
تضرر
يعني جهه عن مجتمع التامين او عن شركات
التامين واسعار مين طبعا اا قطاع التامين
بالكامل الان يخضع للرقابه من خلال البنك
المركزي همم الطموح كبير ذكرها وزير
الماليه في اخر مؤتمر للتامين الطموح كبير
في انه يكون في جهه مستقله هيئه او تكون
جهه رقابيه مستقله بالكامل يعني همم
لهدف او حكمتها القطاع وانهوض بالقطع زي
ما قلتلك فاطمه
القطاع المامون فيه كبير الارقام اللي
تحققت اليوم 40 مليار اا السيارات والطب
بتمثل حوالي 70% همم سوقنا كبير المفروض
انه الرقم يوصل الى 100 مليار حسب السعه
التامينيه اللي موجوده والفاقد اللي
موجوده الان في السوق المحلي همم
يكون في جهه مستقله طيب الحين اليوم ايش
اللي ينقص قطاع التامين لاجل يصير عندنا
مستفيدين راضين همم هل عندنا نواعي ربما
كافيه على اهميه التامين هل عندنا نجاح في
توعيه المستفيد من مين انا اشوف انه هذا
من افضل الاسئله شكرا لك لانه الهدف منه
اليوم في عائق كبير على شركات تامين انت
لا تعتمد فقط انه الدوله اثرت قرار انك
انت لازم تامن اجباري في اعاقه انه انت
الان العميل لم يامن سنه واحده وما يامن
السنه اللي بعدها هذا دور شركات تامين انت
لازم كشركه ان يكون في مخصص لك اللي حملات
التوعيه على موضوع التامين انه هذا راح
يحميك لا قدر الله من اي ضرر اللهم مشاكل
قانونيه ولو بالموضوع بس يعني يقتصر على
تامين السيارات على جميع التامينات
الحوادث الشخصيه من البحري الممتلكات وما
جاب ذلك لكن احنا اليوم السيارات لازم في
وعي او جانب مهم على شركه تامين انه انت
لازم تعمل توعيه للسوق تعمل توعيه
للمؤمنين انه يعني تعطي حوافز للناس انه
تحافظ على التامين وتحافظ على سجلها
التاميني وتساهم برضه مع الجهه الرقابيه
انه تقدر تتوسع فيها القطاع بشكل اكبر
يعني
ان التامين هم مش مجرد همم استماره هو
اكثر من ذلك
اليوم هو الدوله يعني همم
شرعتها شيء والتشاور جاء الرقابيه شرعت
انه يكون اجباري سواء المرور او البنك
المركزي انه تامن ما تجدد استمارات حكومي
او اجراء نظامي الا بعمل التامين لكن انت
كمؤمن انه لازم في عندك الواحد يصير عندك
سجل تامين وانه هذا جزء مهم من قيادتك
للسياره يحافظ عليك لا قدر الله من اي
مسؤوليات قانونيه اي مبالغ ممكن يعني يتم
عليها راح تكون مسؤول عن العلاقه قدر الله
صار حادث في اشياء كثيره انت لازم يكون
عندك الواعي في موضوع التامين وكمان اكيد
استاذ وليد يمكن الاستمراريه في تواجد
التامين الاستمراريه في يكون عندك سجل
مروري نظيف هذه كلها ساهم فان يخفض تكاليف
التامين على المستفيد صحيح انت الان لا
تعتقد انه حنا او شركات التامين بشكل عام
او انك شخص يعني يعطي التوعيه يعني نقول
لك لا تعمل حوادث الحوادث لا قدر الله صار
لازم وجود التامين زي اللي صار مؤخرا في
موضوع السيول في في جده وغير من المدن
التي تظرت بسبب ال- ال- ال- ال- ال- همم
الحوادث اللي صارت هذه التامين مجبر انه
يغطيها الحوادث هذه هذه يعني قدر صار لكن
احنا نقول انه لا تستاهل في عمليه القياده
اليوم شركات التامين عندها معايير مهمه في
تقييم السياره عندها نوع المركبه عمر
السائق نوع السياره مكان قياده السياره
استخدام المركب هل انت مثلا تقود المركبه
همم 20 ساعه فرقا شخص فقط يروح بيته للعمل
ففي مؤشرات مهمه انت لازم تعرفها وتكون
عندك الوعي الكامل في عمليه تسعير التامين
شكرا لتواجدك معنا استاذ وليد الحميد في
استديوهات العربيه بالرياض
استعراض شباب سعوديين في معرض اكسبو الحاج
الذي استضافته جده قبل ايام تعرضوا خدمات
برنامج ضيوف الرحمن والتي تبدا من وصول
الحاج او المعتمر وحتى مغادرته مرورا
بكامل المحطات زيارته المتابعه
[موسيقى]
ثانويه
الحجاج من 57 دوله
من خلال رحله تبدا من الوصول لها التنقل
ثم زياره الحرمين والمشاعر المقدسه مرورا
بتجارب الثقافيه ترسخ في ذاكره الحجاج
والمرتمرين
في مؤتمر ومعرض خدمات الحج والعمره اكسبوا
الحج 20 23 لا اخذكم في جوله لرحله ضيف
الرحمن
هاخذكم ان شاء الله اليوم على المرحله
الاولى الانطباع الاول الانطباع الاول
تتكون من ثلاثه نقاط اتصال ما قبل الوصول
وتشمل كل ما يكون ضد ضيف الرحمن قبل
الوصول كتاشيرات وعندنا قدوم المغادره
ويشمل المنافذ البحريه والجويه والبريه
والتنقل بين المدن
[موسيقى]
المرحله الثانيه هي مرحله اداء المسك اللي
بتساعد في رفع جوده الخدمات اللي موجوده
في المسجد الحرام والمسجد النبوي المشاعر
المقدسه والمواقيت
هنتكلم اليوم على المرحله الثالثه وهي
مرحله اثراء التجربه وفيها مزارع المسار
الضيافه ومسار اكتشاف المملكه وبشاف
المملكه يهتم بالمواقع التاريخيه
والواجبات الاسرائيليه
بناء على الدراسات اللي سمعته عنها تم
تصميم العديد من المبادرات الحكوميه وايضا
الاستثماريه وغير الربحيه والقطاع غير
ربحي كمنظومه يركز عليه البرنامج ويعطيها
ولوويه كبيره في تمكينه من خلال مبادرات
عديده
الشعار البرنامج ومنهجيه هي دائما التفكير
في رحله ضيف الرحمن من الفكره الى الذكرى
[موسيقى]
في جناح البرنامج وهي القاع الاسرائيليه
واللي تعرض اركانها تجربتها ضيوف الرحمن
في الوقت الحالي ضمن رؤيه المملكه 20/03
لضيوف الرحمن من خلال تسهيل الاجراءات
وتسيرها لاستضافه المزيد من المعتمرين
وتهيئه مواقع التاريخ الاسلامي لافراء
التجربه الدينيه والثقافيه للحجاج
والمعتمرين وتحقيق التكامل في الخدمات
لتمكين 30 مليون معتمر من تجربه ايمانيه
من الفكره
محمد الزهراني العربيه جده
رابع مستمره وفيها
30 نحات سعوديا وعالميا يشاركون في ملتقى
التويج للنحت في الرياض
حياكم الله من جديد
شرق السعوديه وبوابه اقتصاديه منذ تاسيس
الدوله واشهدت الداره باهتمام الدوله
بميناء تاريخيا حيث تم تسجيل
الاثار الوطني وترميم مباني المستودعات
والجمارك فيه لافتا الى ان العقير بمحافظه
الاحساء ترتبطوا بمدينه الجرحى القديمه
وتستقي اهميتها التاريخيه من كونها مقر
توقيع معاهده العيار في عهد الملك عبد
العزيز
من الميناء في الاحساء ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي اهلا بك معنا
عبد الرحمن انقل لنا الاجواء وفعاليات
الثقافيه المقامه هناك
نعم فاطمه فعلا هذا الميناء التاريخي
العريق والذي كان اول ميناء بحري في
السعوديه وكان بوابه
القوافل التجاريه وايضا الثقافيه الى
منطقه الاحساء ومن ثم منطقه نجد تقيم هيئه
التراث التابعه لوزاره الثقافه مهرجان
نقوش العقير هذا المهرجان الذي يقام من
خلاله عده فعاليات لعل زميلي نصر ياخذنا
بعض من تفاصيل هذا المهرجان هذا المهرجان
همم فاطمه المفترض انه بدا قبل يومين ومن
المفترض ان يمتد الى تقريبا 10 ايام هذا
المهرجان يضم عده اقسام بوابه الشرق ايضا
مكتب الجوازات ودكه الصيادين ودكه المامور
بالاضافه الى معرض بناء العقير بالاضافه
الى بعض العروض المسرحيه والموسيقيه التي
تقام في هذا المهرجان ايضا الزائر من خلال
مهرجان فاطمه سمر يعني بعدد من المواقع
والمراحل التاريخيه هناك معرض تاريخ ميناء
العقير الذي يعكس تاريخ هذا الميناء وابرز
الاحداث التاريخيه التي مرت بها بالاضافه
طبعا الى محطه القوافل كما نشاد الجمال
هذه الجمال من خلال يتم تعريف خاصه صغار
السن بتاريخ القوافل التجاريه التي كانت
تصل من هذا الميناء وتدخل الى الاراضي
السعوديه بالاضافه طبعا الى دكه الصيادين
ومن خلال هذه الدكه فاطمه يستطيع الزائر
ان يتعرف على مهنه همم الصيد الاسماك
وايضا مهنه انه اخذ
والمصاعب التي كانت تواجه هؤلاء الصيادين
سابقا ايضا دكه البحاره من خلالها ايضا
يتم استعراض الاغاني والموسيقى للبحاره
القدماء او كما يسمى بلغه الموسيقى ان
هامه همم ايضا تقريبا هناك عروض موسيقيه
متتاليه طوال اليوم ايضا يضم هذا الميناء
معرض للسيارات الكلاسيكيه ايضا نشاهد هذه
القوارب القديمه والتي تم وضعها لتعريف
الزائرين بتاريخ مهنه الصيد على شاطئ
ميناء الاجير طبعا الاجواء هنا رائعه
للغايه طبعا غائمه الامطار يعني تذهب
وتعود بين فتره واخرى لكن رغم الظروف
الجويه الا الاقبال يعتبر كثيف جدا خاصه
من اهالي همم
الدمام والخبر يعني ميناء العقير يبعد عن
مدينه الخبر تقريبا ساعه وربع وعن الهفوف
تقريبا ساعه فه وليس ذاك البعد الجغرافي
مما يشجع كثير من العائلات والاطفال
والسيدات ان ياتوا خاصه في الويكند اليوم
السبت يعني ما في دوامات فنشوف الناس
قبالهم كثير جدا على هذا المهرجان للتعرف
على تفاصيل هذا الميناء اي هناك مطاعم
فاطمه شعبيه مطعمين لتقديم الاكلات
البحريه والاكلات الشعبيه بالاضافه الى
بعض المقاهي وايضا بعض الاسر المنتجه
ومشاريع متناهيه الصغر ايضا شاهدتها قبل
قليل في هذا المهرجان ايضا نشاهد هنا جزء
من مسرحيه يتم عرضها للزوار مسرحيه تحكي
عن تاريخ صيد الاسماك وايضا تاريخ
النواخذه يعني فعاليات متنوعه فاطمه فعلا
واقبال همم جيد جدا من قبل الاهالي رغم
الظروف الجويه شكرا لك من ميناء العقير في
الاحساء مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
تستمروا في العاصمه الرياض فعاليات ملتقى
الطويق للنحت في نسخته الرابعه والتي
انطلقت في الثامن من يناير الجاري حتى
العاشر من فبراير القادم الفعاليات التي
تقام تحت شعار مدى الانسجام يشارك فيها 30
نحات محليا ودوليا يستخدمون احجارا من
مناطق مختلفه من السعوديه يتم تحويلها من
كتل صخريه الى اعمال فنيه حيث تتميز
الاحجار المختاره بصلبتها وسلامتها من اي
شقوق او تصدعات وقدرتها على تحمل الضغط
ومقاومته عوامل التعريه المناخيه على
المدى البعيد
من ملتقى الطويق للنحت بالرياض ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم اهلا بك معنا
اسامه ماذا لديك في ملتقى توينك
وا لجميع مشاهدي قناه العربيه بالتاكيد
اليوم اقف في هذه المنطقه في منطقه طويق
للنح طبعا هذا الملتقى ياتي تحت عنوان
مدى الانسجام بالتاكيد هذا الملتقى ايضا
يبحث عن بحث الامور المهمه جدا في موضوع
النحت ايضا كيفيه
التصوير النحت في الحجر والمنحوتات اليوم
هذا الملتقى عدد المسجلين في المبادره او
في المشروع 650 مشارك من 61 دوله هذا
العدد الكبير جدا اتتاب لي يشارك في هذه
الفعاليه الكبرى جدا الا ان المحدد
المشاركين اليوم 30 مشارك في عدد من الدول
العالميه الكبرى طبعا اليوم نتحدث
بالتاكيد عن ان الرياض اصبحت واجهه فنيه
كبرى جدا وواجهه ايضا للفنون والثقافه
والاداب هذا ما جعل ملتقى طريق اليوم الذي
ياتي ضمن مشاريع كبيره جدا لمشروع الرياض
ارت وعدد من البرامج الاخرى التي سوف تنفذ
خلال هذه الفتره اترككم الان في جوله حول
هذه الابداعات وهذه الفنون وهذه الاعمال
التي مازالت يعمل عليها الفنانون في هذه
المنطقه كل من نشاهدهم في الصوره الان هم
نحاتون من دول مختلفه يعملون الان على نحت
الحجر واعمالهم الفنيه التي سوف تكون ان
شاء الله في الايام القادمه همم جاهزه
كليا طبعا نتكلم اليوم بالتاكيد عن اهميه
النحت عن وجود اليوم مشروع الرياض ارت
وعدد من المشاريع التي تعزز اهميه الفن
واهميه النحت اليوم في السعوديه للحديد
اكثر عن هذه المشاريع عن هذه الفعاليه
بالتحديد يا سعود ان يكون معي الان
المهندس خالد الهزاني وهو المدير التنفيذي
لمشروع الرياضات اهلا وسهلا فيك مهندس
ابتدان حياك الله معنا على نشره الرابعه
حدثتني اليوم عن هذه المشروع عن الفنانين
المشاركين وايضا البرامج الاخرى مثل ما
ذكرت عدد اللي يقدم على منطقه 20 23 بلغ
650 في النار تم اعمالهم من قبل اللجنه
الفنيه متخصصه
يضمون سعوديين في اللجنه تم اختيار افضل
30 عام فني ولليوم نشوفهم ينحتون في
الهواء الطرق واللي بتكون فرصه لسكان
وزوار مدينه الرياض لانهم يشاهدون رحله
تحول الكتله الصخريه اللي من الوطن الغالي
الى عمل اعمال فنيه ابداعيه كذلك من
الافعاليات اللي تصاحب ملتقى طويق النحت
عندنا اكثر من 65 وفرشه عمل وتخصصه لجميع
فئات المجتمع طبعا همم طويقنا النحت هو
احد برامج الرياض ارتي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز برؤيه
ومتابع من سمو سيدي ولي العهد والحمد لله
همم اليوم نشهد همم 30 في النهار عالمي من
20 دوله منهم تمام فنانين سعوديين يتكلم
اليوم عن هذا المشروع بالتاكيد عن ملتقى
الطويق كم يستمر ااا هذا الملتقى وايضا هل
هناك اليه للتحكيم او انه مجرد مشاركه
اليوم للفنانين والفنانات يعني نتكلم من
اليوم افضل الاعمال الفنيه الموجوده هل
لها تقييم ام هي افضل الاعمال موجوده التي
ستعرض فقط طبعا الافكار اللي قدمت 56 650
فكره تم تحكيمها من لجنه تحكيم متخصصه
تراعي جوانب كثيره من ضمنها التي اللي هو
عنوان هذا الملتقى
في معايير متحدثده بناء عليها تم اختيار
30 عمل فني كذلك راح يستمر النحت في
الهواء الطلق لمده شهر كامل رحله تحول
الكتله الصخريه راح يشهد ان شاء الله
الزوار اثناء زيارتهم
وتجول ومشاهده المبدعين من الفنانين
مهندس خالد اذا فاطمه تحدث اليوم بالتاكيد
عن كتل صخريه موجوده من السعوديه اليوم ان
احنا همم جاري الان على قدم وساق في
الايام القادمه استشهد هذا همم وفود كبيره
جدا من الزوار والساحل لمشاهد مشاهده هذه
الاعمال وانتقال اليكم شكرا لك اسامه
القاسم والشكر ممتد لضيفك الكريم
مبادرات النوعيه لتحسين جوده الخدمه
العلاجيه لمرضى السرطان اطلقتها جمعيه
تفاؤل في مدينه الاحساء منها مبادره اي
ترميم وتجميل الصدر وتجميد البويضات
للانجاب بتقنيه اطفال الانابيب للمتعافيات
والمصابات بامراض سرطانيه المزيد مع
للغربه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لم تقتصر معاناته ساره السويلم على
اوجاعها الجسديه بسبب مرض سرطان الثدي
الذي اصيبت به قبل اكثر من ست سنوات
لتزداد متاعبها النفسيه والمعنويه ساره
المتعفيه من المرض تعود من جديد لتجدد
عزتها المجتمعيه في اجراء عمليتي ترميم
وتجميل الصدر وذلك بعد استئصاله لتصبح
اليوم اكثر حضوره وتفاعلا في المجتمع
مستفيده من مبادره ترميم الثدي من جامعه
تفاعل الحمد لله
رجعت لي ثقه نفسي وسويت العمليه وانا
الحمد لله احسن حال الحمد لله
مناسبات التي تعيش للمراه خصوصا ايضا في
العلاقات الزوجيه وخصوص العلاقات الخاصه
لا شك انها اثر جدا ممتاز لدى كل سيده
وتجميل الصدر مبادرته اطلقتها جمعيه تفاؤل
لمكافحه السرطان بالاحساء استهدفت حتى
الان 10 مستفيدات اعاده لهن التفاؤلات
والثقه بالنفس فيما تتاهب الجمعيه لاطلاق
مبادره تجميد البويضات للانجاب بتقنيه
اطفال الانابيب والتي وصل عدد التسجيل
فيها الى 30 مستفيده من مصابات بامراض
سرطانيه هناك مبادره
الاولى هي عمليات التجميل او الترميم
الصدر للسيدات والحمد لله الى الان تم
بدءا من جمعيه الاحسان عمليات اقامه خمس
عمليات للسيدات مصردات من الجميع ايضا
بادره الثانيه هي اطفال الانابيب وايضا
جميله
ان تبدا السيده المراحل العلاجيه بامكان
ان تستفيد من هذه الخدمه
تبنتها تفاؤل لرعايه مرض السرطان عبر
التعزيزه للبيئه الرقميه
ماني جوده الخدمات المقدمه للمرضى ورفع
مستوى الوعي المجتمعي من خلال التوعيه
والكشف المبكر وصولا الى تقديم خدمات
متكامله في الجوانب النفسيه والعلاجيه
وكذلك التعليميه والمهنيه من الاحساء عالي
اللغبي العربيه
لمواطنها وباريس تحذر من الانتهاكات
الايرانيه ضد الاجانب
رغم اعلان موسكو سيطرتها الكامله مسؤول
اوكراني يؤكد ان سوليدار تحت سيطره قوات
بلاده
الداخليه السعوديه تعلن عن ضبط اكثر من 15
الف مخالفا لانظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال
اسبوع
شكاوى على مواقع التواصل في السعوديه من
ارتفاع اسعار تامين السيارات والتي تجاوزت
المئتين في المئه اداره الملك عبد العزيز
توثق بناء العقال كاول ميناء بحري سعودي
على الخليج العربي
دمتم بخير
[موسيقى]